herr lauterbach also da wurde ja in den
vergangenen tagen bereits in der bundes
von der bundesregierung die passage
rausgenommen vom von der homepage im
gesundheitsministerium wo es geheißen
hat sinngemäß das sei alles fake news
wenn leute darüber sprechen würden dass
eine allgemeine impfpflicht kommen
könnte ist das schon zeichen dafür ich
spreche hier definitiv nicht also im
namen also der sagen mal das noch
amtierenden gesundheitsminister
oder des robert koch instituts aber ich
bin sage ich mal mit allen also im engen
kontakt und also die zahl derer die eine
impfpflicht für notwendig hält wächst
aber herr lauterbach bei einem respekt
das ist doch das ist doch wieder das
nächste versprechen das sie dann brechen
würden da sitzt der das ist der
ehemalige oder der dann ehemalige
gesundheitsminister hat monatelang
gesagt wenn impfpflicht wird es nicht
geben angela merkel hat gesagt dass wir
irgendwann auch nicht dem urlaub sei
denn dass wir in den ferien ist sie
können doch dann
untergraben sie doch das vertrauen in
eine förderung völlig natürlich das ist
richtig also dass das untergräbt
vertrauen ohne wenn und aber aber wir
müssen anfangen darüber nachzudenken
wenn die also epidemiologie es notwendig
macht dann kann ich nicht sagen es ist
zwar jetzt unbedingt notwendig aber weil
ich damals anders gesprochen habe mache
ich also sollte ich egal was man früher
gesagt nein menschen das blaue vom
himmel vereint unter einem jahr wieder
zu sagten nein egal ist was anderes also
ich muss dann begründen damals haben wir
noch geglaubt das geht ohne jetzt sehen
wir dass also in der kombination wer
soll ihn dennoch irgendetwas glauben
eher lauter auf jeden fall nur die leute
die mir zuhören wenn sie mich
aussprechen lassen sonst wird es nicht
funktionieren also ich werde ich
versuche ja gerade zu erklären was ich
ändern hat und dann also das ist ja
schon mal die voraussetzungen dass man
erst mal erklären kann was neu ist neu
ist wie erreichen ohne impfpflicht
erreichen wir offensichtlich die aus dem
quote nicht die wir benötigen um bei der
stärke der impfstoffe die wir haben
und dem so erwert des der delta variante
über die runden zu kommen also das sind
ja immer drei parameter ist es sozusagen
wie stark sind unsere impfstoff wie
lange wirken die wie staatlich schnell
wie stark ansteckend ist das virus und
jurist die impfquote und wir haben jetzt
das folgende problem die impfstoffe
werden etwas schneller unwirksam die
zahl derer die sich nicht impfen lassen
will ist größer und daher also müssen
wir an dem rad drehen also wie kriegen
wir mehr zur impfungen da kann eine
impfpflicht aus meiner sicht richtig
sein ich würde das auf keinen fall mehr
ausschließen und tendiere dazu zu sagen
das hilft uns jetzt nicht akut aber wir
müssen uns einer impfpflicht nähern das
ist so außenminister hatte am freitag
gesagt das ist alleine rechtlich schwer
möglich möchte einmal die frage
weitergeht mann michael theurer fdp
fraktionsvize der gehandelt wird auch
für ministerposten im neuen kabinett
teurer wenn sie das hören also jetzt
ruckelt auch das versprechen dass eine
impfpflicht kommen nicht kommen soll wie
gehen sie damit um
also zunächst mal ist die aufgabe vor
der wir stehen immens die
geschäftsführende bundesregierung muss
die zeit nutzen die sie derzeit hat die
menschen erwarten dass eben auch um
geschäftsführung
bundesgesundheitsminister dass er sie
nutzt denn
intensivstationen und darauf hat
lauterbach hingewiesen wir sind sehr
sehr voll ich habe mich an unikliniken
gerade jetzt das wissen wir teurer meine
frage war was ist morgens vielleicht ja
ja aber das was wir sehen sind die
versäumnisse der vergangenen wochen da
liegen also jetzt die patienten die sie
vor einigen wochen angesteckt haben und
deshalb ist es so wir brauchen eine
höhere info
und testen sind die zwei seiten einer
medaille
wir sind deshalb auch gerade intensiv
daran zu prüfen ob wir eine impf
nachweispflicht für bestimmte
berufsgruppen einführen gegenüber einer
allgemeinen pflicht haben wir massive
verfassungsbeschwerden gibt es auch
gutachten das die nicht so einfach
einzuführen ist und deshalb lohnt auch
noch mal ein blick nach israel
geschafft die inzidenz auf 33 zu drücken
ohne ihr
versprechen machen sie hier das mit der
fdp keine allgemeine impfpflicht geben
wird wir halten die für verfassungsrecht
sie das
wir sind nicht dafür und wir halten sie
für verfassungswidrig und ich bin der
meinung dass das gut gesetz den guten
verfassung ist
versprechen sie das auch ihren
wählerinnen und wählern dass es eine
impfpflicht eine allgemeine impfpflicht
mit der fdp nicht geben wird hab gerade
auch verwiesen dass wir sie für
verfassungswidrig halten und deshalb sie
in deutschland so nicht einführbar ich
verweise auf israel die ist ohne eben
pflicht schafft durch testen und den
schutzhüllen gruppen und durch eben für
die inzidenz 833 zu drücken und darauf
sollten wir uns konzentrieren aber das
bedeutet ein teurer sie lassen sich
jetzt eine hintertür offen sagen das ist
verfassungswidrig möglicherweise was ist
wenn es nicht verfassungswidrig ist kann
macht die fdp damit
also wir wollen das nicht und wir halten
es mit unserem grundgesetz nicht
vereinbar und wir setzen auch die
überzeugung aber damit keine
missverständnisse aufkommen wir sind
dafür dass sich jeder der das
medizinstudium kann also der gesund ist
impfen lässt ich werde also hier an der
stelle noch einmal ganz klar fürs impfen
und ich bin auch der meinung dass der
moderne impfstoffe genommen werden kann
aber ich kritisiere das jetzt eben
nichts der in deutschland sehr beliebte
impfstoff bei und in ausreichender menge
offensichtlich zur verfügung stehen ich
möchte noch kurz bei der impfpflicht
bleiben hertha hat kaymer wie sehen sie
die debatte um die allgemeine
impfpflicht wenn wir jetzt eine
lauterbach ist dafür eher teurer sagt
jetzt verfassungs richtig gehen sie
davon aus dass am ende eine ampel
regierung diese mit beschließen wird
weiß ich nicht aber ich kann satz so zu
sagen was ich für nötig halte wo
anderthalb jahren hielt ich es für nötig
dass wir eine kontakt verfolgung
bekommen und uns überhaupt datenschutz
bedenken hinwegsetzen hat mir bis heute
nur ärger eingebracht wir haben keine
funktionierende kontakt verfolgung jetzt
haben wir einen impfstoff der könnte die
probleme lösen wenn nur genügend
benutzen würden ich habe festgestellt
die erste phase der argumente die ist
vorbei mit argumenten scheint man
niemand mehr zu überzeugen dann wurde
mit druck gearbeitet
dann ist die zahl der erstimpfung aber
gar nicht angestiegen september und
oktober sind die erste impfungen auf
extrem niedrigen niveau geblieben und
jetzt stellt sich schon die frage wenn
wir ohne impfungen kaum eine chance
haben diese ewige spirale aus kontakt
beschränkungen und mögliche
schulschließungen was da alles auf uns
zukommt zu durchbrechen was wollen wir
dann tun mit argumenten klappt's nicht
mittrug und kosten und zweig hat es
nicht geklappt und dann scheint es mir
irgendwie ziemlich logisch zu sein zu
sagen okay diese gesellschaft die
braucht jetzt eine form des
zusammenhalts pflicht ist ja auch nichts
böses sondern pflicht spürt man erstmal
selber und die gießen der in form eines
gesetzes ich finde es schlüssig weil wir
anders nicht vorangekommen sind leider
muss man manchmal zu solchen
konsequenzen greifen und ich kann mir
auch nicht vorstellen als
verfassungswidrig ist wenn es gibt ja
immerhin eine masern impfen licht und
ich kann jetzt nicht erkennen das maß an
unsere gesellschaft in so gravierender
weise bedroht wie es derzeit die korona
pandemie tut aber wegen masern
eigentlich doch keine kontakt
beschränkungen oder schwer wiegen den
gesellschaftlichen eingriffe in
grundrechte und freiheiten vorgenommen
deswegen meine ich dass es zulässig ist
und das ist allmählich zeit wird zu
diesem instrument zu greifen